[Musique]
et cette invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
Delphine Papin bonjour bonjour bienvenue
sur ce plateau vous êtes géographe et
vous dirigez le service de l'infographie
de la cartographie du quotidien Le Monde
depuis
5 ou 6 ans vous avez aussi dirigé cette
ouvrage Atlas géopolitique de la Russie
qui est sorti aux arènes dans lequel on
retrouve une centaine de cartes et
d'infographies et certaines plumes bien
connues du quotidien du soir qu'on salue
un livre extrêmement riche dont le
propos est de remettre la Russie sur la
carte ou la carte sur la Russie une
Russie qui en envahissant l'Ukraine au
mois de février dernier à soulever
écrivez-vous la plus inflammable des
questions géopolitiques celle des
frontières alors commençons donc par le
commencement et par les cartes qui
ouvrent l'ouvrage et qui reviennent sur
1200 ans d'histoire
territoire territoriale russe que nous
disent-elles alors on a commencé par
ouvrir effectivement cette Atlas par des
cartes historiques puisque dans le
discours de Vladimir Poutine il fait
appel à l'histoire beaucoup sont son
discours serait
véritablement cartographiable et donc il
fait souvent des références à l'Empire
et des références à l'URSS enfin pas de
cette manière là mais voilà donc c'était
important pour nous en tout cas de
d'avoir un outil pour permettre aux
lecteurs de savoir quels sont à quoi il
fait référence quand ils parlent à ça
alors en 2016 vous le citez Vladimir
Poutine disait que les frontières de la
Russie ne se terminaient nulle part
cette petite phrase dit beaucoup de la
façon dont il se représente à la fois le
monde et son pays à quel moment
l'histoire si toutefois il y en a un la
Grande Russie de Vladimir Poutine
correspond-t-elle alors il fait
référence en fonction des territoires
qui le veut
récupérer
ce qui est sûr c'est que sur toutes les
questions de la mer Noire puisque votre
correspondant sur place était à
proximité il fait référence à la mer
Noire autant de Catherine II à savoir
cette mère qui était plutôt une mère
russe plutôt qu'une qu'un lac au Tania
on sait aujourd'hui bien sûr qu'il n'y a
à l'Ukraine son caractère national c'est
tout le sujet de l'invasion du mois de
février dernier
il y a des frontiers c'est un pays qui a
des frontières en tout cas officieuses
en tout cas selon Moscou mouvante ce qui
est assez rare aujourd'hui ou en tout
cas sur le continent européen quel est
le statut aujourd'hui de ces nouvelles
frontières entre guillemets je pense par
exemple à la Crimée d'ailleurs ça ne
vous a pas échappé la Crimée qui est sur
la couverture de l'ouvrage qui est
englobée dans cette Russie oui alors en
fait bah alors sur sur le caractère de
la couverture effectivement on a fait un
choix qui était le choix de montrer la
manière dont Vladimir Poutine se perçoit
son territoire et perçoit le territoire
de ses voisins donc avec ce territoire
qu'il a annexé on a eu un référendum en
2014 qui a été conduit par la Russie et
sur lequel la communauté internationale
ne reconnaît pas du tout cette annexion
on a eu ensuite d'autres territoires qui
ont été annexés récemment et pareil de
la même manière la communauté
internationale ne reconnaît pas
ses frontières là et d'ailleurs sur les
espaces que Vladimir Poutine a annexé
officiellement selon la Russie
ce ne sont pas des territoires qu'il
occupent totalement c'est à dire qu'il y
a encore des zones où
l'extension de de l'armée n'a pas été
jusque là et pour autant il les a déjà
enveloppés comme lui appartenant voilà
donc il a une différence entre bien sûr
sur cette question des frontières entre
la perception qu'on fait la Russie et le
droit international exactement
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant de le voir
en carte parce que ça c'est difficile à
expliquer à l'oral et je j'irai très
vite si je vous ai une carte où je
superposais à la fois l'avancée des
troupes russes et à la fois les
territoires officiellement Ann et vous
verriez que ces territoires ne
correspondent pas à la réalité
simplement militaire actuelle pour
revenir à la Crimée et vous l'expliquez
par une nymphographie également dans
cette Atlas l'annexion correspond bien
sûr à des ambitions géopolitiques mais
aussi à une réalité démographique la
population de la Crimée c'est beaucoup
finalement par rapport à la population
en russe qui est quasiment qui est en
déclin depuis la chute de l'URSS oui
c'est ça ça nous semblait intéressant de
le montrer c'est à dire qu'il y a une
page qui qui raconte la démographie
russe c'est à dire quand même quand on
regarde quand on regarde une carte c'est
un petit peu trompeur une carte mondiale
puisque vous avez un territoire qui est
le plus vaste du monde qui va de la
Chine jusque
jusqu'à jusqu'aux États-Unis par
l'Alaska et qui va aussi jusqu'à
l'Europe et puis en fait vous avez une
population qui n'est pas si importante
que ça à savoir c'est la France plus
l'Allemagne réunie et dont la
concentration se concentre sur le flanc
ouest le flan ouest près de près de
l'Europe et donc donc
qu'effectivement c'est un pays qui est
pas si peuplé que ça par rapport à
l'image qu'on peut s'en faire quand on
regarde une carte et
l'annexion de la Crimée avait
effectivement fait
rapporter entre guillemets une
population bien plus importante enfin
2,3 millions pour être précis
d'habitants à la Russie en l'espace de
quelques mois en 2014 vous rappelez
aussi dans cet ouvrage que Vladimir
Poutine est un président guerrier un
président belliqueux mais qui à l'image
du conflit en Ukraine même pas utiliser
le mot guerre absolument d'ailleurs on y
fait on y fait attention
on y a fait attention pour pour protéger
les correspondants qu'on avait sur place
et
voilà enfin c'est effectivement c'est
c'est un terme qui est toujours
compliquée à utiliser pas du tout mis en
Russie en Russie on ne peut pas
qualifier la guerre
bien sûr à ce propos je voulais qu'on
regarde une carte alors une infographie
pour le coup qui est pas 110 qui est
assez intéressante et qui est un peu
contre-intuitive qui fait le lien entre
la courbe de popularité de Vladimir
Poutine et les guerres qu'il mène vous
pouvez peut-être nous la nous la
décrypter oui voilà alors en fait c'est
qui alors voilà en fait c'est une courbe
qui montre la popularité de Vladimir
Poutine et en fait l'idée de cette idée
qu'on voulait ici montrer c'était que à
chaque fois en rouge vous avez des
grands moments par exemple si on prend
le point rouge sur l'annexion de la
Crimée vous voyez que ça courbe de
popularité monte donc elle est
contre-intuitive parce qu'on pourrait se
dire que quand en guerre quand on rentre
en guerre les populations pourraient ne
pas vouloir y aller et donc la
popularité de Poutine baissée mais non
en fait à chaque fois dans l'histoire
récente de de Vladimir Poutine enfin
l'histoire récente non en fait on a
couvert tout son tout tous ces
différents mandats à chaque fois qu'il
entre en guerre la courbe de popularité
russe l'opinion russe monte
favorablement pour lui alors sachant
qu'il est aujourd'hui alors je ne sais
pas de quel chiffre il s'agit mais selon
le chiffre que vous reprenez 83%
d'opinion favorables en mai dernier et
clairement la courbe est ascendante
après l'invasion de la guerre en Ukraine
et je dis contre-intuitive parce que
bien sûr on le sait que tous les Russes
ne suivent pas Vladimir Poutine sur
l'invasion de l'Ukraine toutefois ce
chiffre ferait rêver des dirigeants
occidentaux oui alors après il y a toute
la question de l'information ou de la
désinformation en Russie qui qui
explique cette courbe oui l'invasion de
l'Ukraine et vous le rappelez bien sûr
dans cet ouvrage et bien sûr venu
remettre au centre enfin redistribuer
les cartes remettre au centre la
confrontation avec l'OTAN il y a une
infographie passionnante sur le rapport
de force militaire pour le contre l'OTAN
et la Russie rebattre les cartes avec le
voisin chinois je voulais vous qu'on
évoque les conséquences sur les
ambitions alors là c'est le comparatif
des forces armées entre l'OTAN et la
Russie clairement en faveur de l'OTAN
mais je voulais qu'on en voit une autre
celle sur sur les ambition africaine de
Vladimir Poutine sujet qui nous
intéresse particulièrement ici à France
24 est-ce que vous diriez que avec ce
titre intéressant d'ailleurs vers la rue
safrique est-ce que vous diriez que ça a
rebattu aussi les cartes cette guerre en
Ukraine sur le les liens entre la Russie
le continent oui alors on l'a vu il y a
une autre partie de la page qui pourrait
être intéressante à regarder c'est les
votes des pays africains
en faveur de voilà et enfin en faveur à
l'ONU en faveur du du pardon de des
sanctions merci excusez-moi et on voit
que un certain nombre de pays africains
ne se sont pas prononcés sur cette
question là c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont
pas dit qui qui soutenaient les
sanctions mais on ne se prononçant pas
contre on sent que la Russie a une
influence grandissante au détriment des
anciens pays
du pré carré africain elles sont
évidemment la à premier première ligne
il y a un autre élément sur cette carte
les pays qui sont en rose ce sont ceux
qui ont signé un accord de coopération
militaire avec Moscou dont énormément
écrivez-vous d'État autoritaire ou des
tas dites-vous qui ont failli je renvoie
à ce sujet d'en parler tout à l'heure
dans la revue de presse à l'article du
Monde aujourd'hui qui parle des
agissements des troupes de wagnères au
Soudan vous dites dans cet ouvrage que
le conflit a changé la donne pour vous
les cartographes et les géographes
peut-être plus généralement et en
illustration je voudrais qu'on regarde
une carte qui a été établie de la
situation à Mario Paul je crois que
c'était au mois de mai oui dites nous
pourquoi cette carte à ce moment-là de
l'histoire dit des choses que des
reporters ne pourraient pas dire alors
en mai en mai 2022 on est dans un moment
où il est très difficile d'accéder à
Mario Paul il y a plus de journalistes
internationaux sur le terrain et donc ou
très peu je crois qu'il reste une ou
deux équipes et donc l'accès à
l'information l'accès à ce qui se passe
sur le terrain et bien on l'a on a pu
nous la raconter via des images
satellites ou des images qui provient
qui proviennent de radar et donc ce qui
était intéressant de montrer sur cette
carte c'est à dire que vous voyez tous
les tous les petits mouchetés rouges et
jaunes en fait représentent les les
bombardements ou les zones endommagées
sur sur cet espace de Mario Paul à
l'époque on raconte que les cibles de la
Russie
se concentre essentiellement sur des
zones stratégiques comme effectivement
vous en avez entendu parler la zone
industrielle
d'azoft Stal et en fait quand on prend
les images satellites et qu'on les
étudie et qu'on regarde toutes ces zones
endommagées on voit bien que aussi bien
les quartiers résidentiels et donc les
civils sont
touchés par les bombardements que la
zone industrielle des obstacles donc
c'était une manière d'être présent dans
cette zone où on
n'y voyait pas grand chose et mais le
cartographe là peut avoir un apport
intéressant pour pour comprendre une
situation voilà l'effet rétabli grâce à
la carte merci beaucoup grâce aux cartes
merci beaucoup Delphine Papin nous avoir
parlé de cet ouvrage exercice difficile
que de résumer quoi 200 pages de cartes
visuellement comme ça mais ça c'est
vraiment un atlas que je vous invite à
ouvrir qui est extraordinairement riche
évidemment très bien illustré et très
intéressant et pas que là on a on a dû
faire un peu vite mais sur la guerre en
Ukraine merci beaucoup d'être venu nous
en parler on se retrouve juste après la
pause avec Florent rodo pour la suite de
Paris direct à tout de suite
[Musique]